gerçekten çok güzel bir gün geçiyor
Bugün sabahtan beri izlediğim her
Dinlediğim her konuşmacıdan farklı bir
ilham aldım Fakat benim bir kehanetim
var bu kehaneti Hemen şimdi 14 15
dakikada değil Şimdi söyleyeyim ve
gideyim istiyorum
önümüzdeki 10 yıl içerisinde şu anda
kullanmakta olduğunuz mobil
aplikasyonlarının ve web sitelerinin en
az yarısını unutacaksınız
bu kehaneti
oluşturmak için ya da konuşmak için
benim hani önünde bir kürem yok Bir
kristal küreden bakıp bunu söylemiyorum
sadece geçmişten gelen 90'lı yıllara
baktığımızda 2000'li yıllara
baktığımızda 2010'lara ve şimdiye
baktığımızda geçen süreçteki
izlenimlerinden Hani bunu çıkartıyorum
bunu çok rahat Siz de
çıkartabileceksiniz ben Murat Canbaz bir
tasarımcıyım tasarım eğitimi aldım ve
pek çok şeyden bu süreçte ilham aldım
hem aldığım konulardan bir tanesi
aslında şöyle söyleyeyim bugünkü
konuşmamda aldığım iki tane ilhamı Size
söyleyeceğim Bunlardan size bahsedeceğim
ikinci bölümde bu aldığım ilhamları
nasıl hayatıma geçirdim ve
gerçekleştirdim neler yaptım çok kısa
olunca onlardan bahsedeceğim sonra ben
hani bir ilhamda size vermek istiyorum
eğer hani Ee Mümkün olursa
tasarım okuduğum dönemde üniversitede
Aslında tasarımı sadece estetiğin konusu
olmadığını anladım ve Hani tasarım Eğer
çözdüğü sorunlarla da ilintili olarak
bir katma değer sağlıyorsa tasarımdır
noktasına eriştik çok sevdiğim değer
verdiğim Sevgili Hocam Turgut Tuna'nın 3
tane tasarımla ilgili 3E kuralı vardı
Eğer bir şey tasarım olacaksa bu Estetik
olmak zorunda
ergonomik olmak zorunda ve mutlaka
ekonomik olmak zorunda yani tasarım
aslında bir sorunu çözmesi gerekiyor ki
Ancak hani Ee yerine değerini bulsun
sonra Rönesans öğrenmeye başladık bizim
müfredatımızda bile rönesansı vardı Bu
arada ben
dediğim gibi güzel sanatlar okudum 4
yıllık bir fakülteydi ben Okulu 7 yılda
bitirdim
çok kısa Bu hikayede sıkıştırayım araya
3 senemizdeyiz ve
müfredatımızdır Rönesans Evet beni çok
heyecanlandıran bir konu
Fakat o dönem üniversitede
öğretmenlerimiz farklı bir Ee kişiyi ve
Rönesans yerine bizi
size İslam sanatlarını anlatıyor işte
hangi camide hangi medresede kaç sütünü
var Ne var ne yok ya ortasına kadar
geldik okulun yani dönemin ortasına
kadar geldik Bunlar bitmiyor
Ben dersin ortasında kalktım hocam dedim
yani bunları anlatıyorsunuz Ama
rönesansı biz ne zaman işleyeceğiz
işlemeyeceksiniz dedi Nasıl yani ben
bunu okumak için geldim Hayırdır
işlemeyeceksiniz bunları göreceksiniz
niye benleri 25 yıl önce bunları gördüm
Siz de bugün bunları göreceksiniz ama
bizim hedefimiz farklı yok dedi Bunlar
olacak
sinirlendim hocam dedim Ya kusura
bakmayın benden kaldınız dedim ve
sınıftan çıktım gittim 3 sene sonra
geldim 3 sene sonra hoca değişti
müfredat arıyor lisans koyuldu ve ben
onu oradan aldım ve devam ettim bu
enteresan en kısa bir hikayeydi Rönesans
şunu söylüyordu arkadaşlar mesela sadece
estetik ve güzel resimlerin güzel
heykellerin yapıldığı bir dönem değil
aslında insana dair değerlerinde ön
plana çıktığı ciddi toplumsal sorunların
da çözüm bulduğu devrimsel bir süreç
Bunu gördük bunu öğrendik
O zaman ben bu okuldan mezun olduğumda
şunu yapmalıyım ne yaparsam yapayım
mutlaka insana dair bir
noktada değmiş olayım ve bir sorunu
çözmüş olayım aynı dönemde okulda
okurken bir gazetede yerel Ben
Bursalıyım Bu arada Bursa'da yerel bir
gazetede hem mizanpaj yapıyorum Hem köşe
yazarlığı yapıyorum
Kültür Sanat köşesi yönetiyorum Hani
tasarımcıyım ya eğitim de almışım o
dönemde
[Müzik]
bilgisayarda tasarım yapmakla ilgili
Photoshop diye bir şey çıkmış Photoshop
bir sıfır Şimdi bilmiyorum artık Kaç III
versiyonuna kadar çıktı
Onun inceliyorum final 2-0'dan fazladır
büyük ihtimalle
onu inceliyorum ve bir şeyler
karıştırıyorum Sonra şöyle bir soru
çıktı teknolojik sanat olur mu yani
internette bir internet yok tabii
bilgisayarda yaptığımız bir şey ee
karşılığında Hani tasarım olarak bir
değer görür mü bu nereye oturur
tartışmayı açtım Bununla ilgili makale
yazdım bugün son 1 yıldır 2 yıldır belki
Yani nfc'leri takip ediyorsanız o
tartışma Hala sürüyor Ben bunu 30 sene
önce sormuştum bu sorular bitmiyor hani
bir şey yapmak istiyorum tasarlamaya
devam etmek istiyorum ama hani diğer
taraftan da teknoloji ile ilgili bir
açlığım var Onu da doyurmam gerekiyor
İnternet diye bir şey çıkmış yani
ortalık kapıp kavuruyor 90'lı yılların
sonları
sevgili Elif daha ile tanıştım ve onun
hayalleriyle Benim hayallerim çok güzel
böyle ortak bir noktada faydalı buluştu
Ee bir arama motoru yapmak istediğini
söyledi Tamam dedim Bunu ben
tasarlayacağım çünkü o dönem
gördüğüm bir sıkıntı vardı internet
siteleri tasarımdan çok uzak font yok
renk Yok işte yok Yani inanılmaz kötü
dedim ben bunu beraber yapacağız ve ben
orada
artractice olarak görev aldım ve Uzunca
bir süre çalıştık daha sonra Hayallerim
çok hani Ajans deneyimlerim de var Evet
çeşitli reklam ajanslarında çalışmışım
geleneksel ajanslar Bunlar ama internet
gelişiyor Ben yönümü internet tarafından
yönettiğim ve d-4d adını verdiğim
bir şirket kurdum ortağımla beraber
yaklaşık Bu şirket 15 yıl kadar Eee
hizmet verdi 15 yılın sonunda pek çok
şirket gibi bunu da kapatmak zorunda
kaldık çeşitli sebeplerden dolayı ama
orada 35 kişiyle inanılmaz işler yaptık
yaklaşık 1000'e yakın Ee firmaya
servisler verdik Hatta bu servis
verdiğimiz firmalardan bir tanesi de
aramızda Az önce karşılaştık Merhabalar
herkese memnun filan ama ben memnun
değilim çünkü yapmak istediğim çok fazla
şey var
yine aynı dönemde bir derdimiz var bizim
bu dertle ilgili de bir girişim yaptık
isminde gazogen dedik dedik bu da bugün
bakın tarih 2003
Bugün Türkiye'de dünyada metaforce diye
bir şeyden bahsediliyor bugün bakıp
2003'e baktığımızda Evet ya adamlar
yapmış Türkiye'de ilk metabol Projesi
olarak Ee gaza gel Eee marketmiş durumda
yıllar geçiyor benim merakım bitmiyor
tasarlamak yani eksikleri gidermekle
ilgili bu sektörde bir şeyler yapmakla
ilgili heyecanım bitmiyor oturuyorum bir
şeyler düşünüyorum Evet mobil
teknolojileri gelişiyor internet hızları
artıyor sene olmuş 2007 ama bununla
ilgili hala bir çözüm yok hala bir sonuç
gelmemiş karşımıza
o Şeyin adını verdiğin bir tane proje
gerçekleştiriyorum Bu proje 1 yıl kadar
hayatta kaldı sonra ne girişim alabildik
ne destek alabildik ne elimizden tutan
olabildik kapatmak zorunda kaldım ne
yapıyordu bu iş
bir arama motoruydu birincisi dünyadaki
bütün video sitelerinden Ee verileri
alıp size bir sonuç döndürüyordu bu bir
ikincisi
ücretli olarak içinde film
izleyebildiğiniz ve kiralayabildiğiniz
bir sistemi var zaten
2007'de Ben bunu kapattım 2008'de duyduk
ki netflix artık
DVD kiralamaktan vazgeçmiş ve ondiment
yayın yapacağını duyurmuş enteresan Biz
bunu düşündük Ama işte elimizden
tutamamayınca gerçekleştiremedik şimdi
ne yapıyorum bugün bir dijital pazarlama
şansım var tek tabanca hizmet veriyorum
Hem eğitim hem de danışmanlık yapıyorum
meteorge Ve nff üzerine ve 3-0 üzerine
danışmanlık verdiğiniz ve eğitimler
verdiğimiz bir şirketin ortağıyım
düventi dediğimiz intermond dünyasına
farklı bir pencere açacak Bir web 3
projemiz var onun girişi mor Time Lügat
adını verdiğim bir de sözlüğüm var
bugünlerde üzerinde çalıştı
ilgili bir hikayem var bir de gazoz
Hikayem Var Benim
Yok yok öyle bir şey yok yani Öyle öyle
bir şey olmadı
yıllardan işte 2002-2003 ve chat
yapmakla ilgili sohbet etmekle ilgili
yeni insanlarla tanışmakla ilgili merak
var O dönemlerde iki tane platform var
Birincisi mülk dediğimiz Yani yaşı 40'ın
üzerinde olan arkadaşlarımız hatırlarlar
bir platform var bir de Ice q var birkaç
tane de şey var ve ekran Arkadaşlar bu
yani bugün sosyal medyaya dair ne varsa
iletişime dair ne varsa böyle bir
Ekrandan bir Hani takılıyorduk ve
buradan hallediyorduk işlerimizi tanışma
ve sosyalleşmeyi ihtiyaçlarımızı
gideriyorduk
Bursa'dan bir tane firma aradı bizi evin
büyük bir meşrubat firmasını ve arkasını
vermeyeceğim
ve dedi ki ya Bize bir tane web sitesi
lazım çocuklar gelin Bursa'ya tanışalım
bizim Bir web sitesi yapın ama öyle bir
web sitesi olsun ki biz gençleri ve
çocukları hedefliyoruz şöyle renkli bir
şeyler olsun Altına da bir müzik
başarsiniz süper olur döndük
tasarımcıyız 2 ortağıyız orta As
sektörde
sosyalleşmekle ilgili bir şey var Bir
açık var yapmak istediğimiz hayalleri
Hayal kurduğumuz farklı bir şeyler var
ve hani birkaç senedir üzerine
çalıştığımız bir altyapı var dedik ki
biz bunu bu şeye yapabiliriz bu firmaya
uygulayabiliriz
Görselleştirmek Yani az önce gösterdiğim
o kalabalık ekranı daha stilize daha
görsel hale getirmekle ilgili bir
çalışma gerçekleştirmeye başladık çizdik
haritalar çizdik olmuyor çünkü hani bir
figürü koyduğunuz zaman o haritanın
üzerinde farklı bir üste çıkıyor Biz
bunu yan çevirmemiz lazım izometrik bir
hale getirmemiz lazım izometrik izdüşüm
diye bir şey uydurduk bugün boksör
diyorlar ona
ve biz bu izometrik izdüşümün içerisinde
karakterimizi koyduk karakterine de bazı
engeller koyduk ok engellilere Hani
takılıp gidiyor mu gitmiyor mu ona
bakacağız yazılımı yaptık algoritmayı
çizdik yani Yapay Zeka demeyeyim ama
bayağı bir algoritmik bir yapı var
aslında Evet o engellediğini etrafından
dolaşan bir figür oluşturmuş olduk biz
bunu bir görselleştirelim bu figürü Hani
bir de hani hareket katalım saç yaptık
kıyafet yaptık ayakkabı ayaklarını
gövdesini vesairesini oluşturduk ve
yüzlerce binlerce Avatar oluşturduk
Avatar kelimesini O gün o dönemlerde
içerisine girdik
Oma yine aldık ve gittik Bursa'ya
patronla Hani birebir görüşüyoruz
dedi ki Ne yaptınız işte hani böyle bir
şey yaptık aa süpermiş nasıl İşte bunlar
yürüyecekler mekanlar içerisinde
gezecekler falan süper harika
ne kadar dedi hani bizim borcumuz ne
Ödeyeceğiz buna biz ortağımla bunun
zaten Hani fizibilitresini yapmıştık kaç
kişi çalışır ne kadar çalışırız vesaire
5000 dolar bir rakam var ihtiyacımız var
Biz bunu hayata geçirmek istiyoruz yani
zengin olmak gibi niyetimiz yok 5 bin
dolar
patron gözünüzün içine baktı gözler Fal
taşı gibi açıldı çocuklar dedi Ne
yapıyorsunuz siz Abi ne yapıyoruz dedik
oğlum dedi kaç paralık elektrik
yakacaksınız dedi 5.000 dolar Biz
ortaklık yani göz göze geldik hadi abi
dedik gidelim Bizim işimiz gücümüz var
iş yapacağız Döndük dolaştık ve bu
projeyi Kendimiz için gerçekleştirdik
gazoz Dünyası dedik gazogen dedik ismine
ve o günlerde Türkiye'de dört buçuk
milyon ile 5 milyon arasında değişen bir
internet kullanıcısı sayısı vardı biz 1
milyon kullanıcı sayısına eriştik 1
milyon üye sayısını eriştik ve Aslında
bunu yaparken de Eee farklı bir dijital
alanda Ee Reklamcılık Ee
mecrası oluşturduğumuzda fark ettik
firmaların maskotları vardı bu
maskotları işte hani yaptığımız sistemin
içerisinde dahil etmeye başladık farklı
markalar için farklı
oluşumlar gerçekleştirdik mekanlar
oluşturduk ve bunları içerisinde o
etkileşimi sürdürmeye başladık biz bunu
yaptığımızda
henüz
Facebook'un Hani düşlerinde bile değildi
belki Çünkü 5 yıl sonra Facebook oluştu
ilk tweet 6 yıl sonra atıldı Biz bunu
2003 senesinde yaptık şimdi bir
kehanetin var demiştin ya ben size ne
diyor ki Kehanet bugün
kullanmakta olduğunuz mobil
aplikasyonların ve web sitelerinin en az
yarısını önümüzdeki 10 yıl içinde Onun
çıkacaksınız nasıl ben kendi yaptığım
işi gazogeni unuttuysam o şeyini
unuttuysam ve diğerlerini unuttuysam Bu
bir kaç kaçınılmaz bir süreç nereden
biliyoruz
şu anda kullanmakta olduğumuz dönem
web2.0 dönemi ve Aslında binlerce on
binlerce yüzbinlerce
servis veren web sitesi var etrafımızda
Hadi bunları biraz böyle
Optimize edelim en yakın dönemde Yakın
tarihte kullandığımız ve en çok
kullandığımız
aplikasyonları bir araya getirdiğimizde
bakın friendf artık hatırlamıyoruz yani
40 yaş üstü belki hatırlar My space.com
diye bir şey vardı gitti diye bir şey
vardı Artık yeni Instagram'a bıraksın
diye bir şey vardı Facebook çıkınca o da
gitti
karşımızda kalan bazı uygulamalar var
ama bunlar da artık gitmeye yüz tutuyor
Niye Çünkü biz şu anda bir dönüşüm bir
değişim bir devrimin eşindeyiz dedim ya
hani rönesans'tan bahsettim ben
rönesans'a bağlayacağım 2 dakika 27
saniye var Çok özür dilerim hızlı
geçeceğim ve 1-0 döneminde
bir veriyi almak için
mutlaka Hani bir sunucuya bağlanmanız ve
Sunucunun arkasındaki web sitesinden
ek olarak o veriyi çekmeniz gerekiyordu
bu 90'lı yıllarla 2000'li yıllar
arasındaki durumdu 2000'lerde 2000'in
ortasına doğru artık işin içerisine User
generated content'e girdi yani
kullanıcıda içerik üretmeye başladı
Facebook'ta fotoğraflarımızı paylaştık
Instagram'da fotoğraflarımızı
videolarımızı paylaşmaya başladık
bloglarda yazılarımızı yazmaya başladık
Ama hala bir sunucu var arkada ama o
Sunucunun sahibi büyük troller yani
büyük firmalar milyar dolarlık firmalar
facebook'lar ınstagram'lar vesaire
vesaireler arka tarafta büyük bir şey
var şimdi web 3-0 dediğimiz dünya artık
ortadaki sunucu olayın ortadan
kaldırıyor bir yırtıp bir iletişim
başlıyor Yani bu ne demek bu aslında bir
dönüşüm bir değişim falan değil bu
devrimin ta kendisi iletişim kurmaya
başladığınız zaman o aradaki bütün
servis verenlere ihtiyacınız kalmayacak
arkadaşlar dünya Aslında iletişim
çağında iletişim konusunda çok enteresan
bir yere doğru gidiyor o yüzden aslında
ben Gergin değilim Sadece o biraz daha
dikkatli bakabiliyorum şeye
bu konulara
servisler geliyor arkası arkadan Yani
ben birkaç tanesini sizin için burada
hızlı bir şekilde
örnekledim burada tahmin ediyorum Hani
sizin tanıdığınız markalarda var Bunlar
ve hep 3-0'a kendini hazırlayabilen
markalar Bunlar varlıklarını Muhtemelen
sürdürecekler Ama bu değişime bu
dönüşümü görmeyen markalar maalesef Eee
Hani tarihin tozu sayfaları arasında
kendi yerlerini bulacak
nedir bu dönüşümün göstergeleri Ben niye
bunu görüyorum nasıl bunu yani şey
yapabiliyorum Bir de size küçük bir
örnek vereceğim sonra kapatacağım
NFC yolundayız ve Hani son 1-2 yıldır
artık nftlerle ilgili çok şey duyuyoruz
çok şey görüyoruz
Bu ekranda gördüğünüz NFC 2017 yılında
yayınlanmışım olan bir Evdi bakın 8 bit
dediğimiz bir Hani teknikle Yapılmış
küçük küçük piksellerden oluşmuş şeyi
hatırlar mısınız 90'lı yıllarda cep
telefonlarımızda Hani bizim logo
melodiyi yüklerdik var mı onları
yapanlar yine yazışıyorsunuz çıkacak
ortaya Ee
onlar bir dönem çok modaydı sonra
birdenbire mm çıktı Sonra aradan 4-5
sene daha geçti artık cep
telefonlarımızdan gb'ler dolusu verileri
indirmeye başladık yani süreci bunun
gözümüzün önünde yaşandı bu süreç en
etkiler de aynı şekilde bakın
piksellerle başladı Refik Anadolu'nun
devasa Eee şu anda gb'ler dolusu şeyleri
var eserleri var karşımızda
ve Aslında gelen görünüyor görünüyor
gelmekte olan çok basit bir tane küçük
bir örnek vereceğim size
bir tane bir yönetmen olduğunuzu düşünün
dünyanın en ünlü yönetmenlerinden bir
tanesini ya da in the yönetmensiniz bir
projeniz var Bu proje ile ilgili bir dağ
kuruyorsunuz
otonom organization ve insanlara
soruyorsunuz Ben nasıl bir film çekeyim
o insanlar onu Karar verecekler ve
bununla ilgili Belki sizi fonlayacaklar
ve siz o filminizi o insanlar için
sadece o insanların göreceği şekilde
yapıp NFC olarak verebileceksiniz Çok
yakında biz bunları göreceğiz Bu bize
Hani dedim ya resmen Devrim Yani bu Yapı
hiç bir de küçük bir örnek vereyim
meteoroloji Hani önümüzdeki 10 yıl
içerisinde 3 trilyon dolarlık bir
ekonomi yaratacak deniyor Ben bir
araştırdım 3 trilyon dolar ne kadar para
yapıyor diye Dünya üzerinde dolaşımda
olan dolarların sizin benim Cebimdeki
bankalardaki şirketlerdeki doların
tamamını bir araya getirirseniz bir
nokta yedi trilyon dolar yapıyor Yani
bunun 2.000 üstünden fazla bir şeyden
bahsediyoruz yapıdan bahsediyoruz
rönesans'a hemen atıfta yapıp
bitiriyorum çok özür dilerim Son bir
dakikada rica ediyorum sizden insana
dair planları
diğerlerinden yapılan öne çıktığından
bahsetmiştik niye rönesans'a
benzetiyorum Ben bakın mankenlik
sisteminin çöküşü rönesans'ta yaşandı
şimdi kripto'dan bahsediyoruz hümanizmin
doğuşu rönesansınız Rönesans yapan
noktalardan bir tanesiydi biz şimdi
merkeziyetsizlik konuşuyoruz sanat
edebiyat heykel Bunlar geliştiriyor
esasında bizde en etkiler ve yaratıcı
kondan bahsediyoruz mimari bilim ve
matematik Rönesans'ın bel kemiği de
bugün ona karşılık olarak da metaller
var yani bir devrim var siz bu devrimin
neresindesiniz kendinize nasıl bir alan
açtınız Kendinizi bu devr nasıl
hazırlıyorsunuz Çok teşekkür ederim
bilmediğiniz için
[Alkış]